federal immigration agents are
escalating efforts to crack down on
businesses hiring undocumented workers
new data released this morning shows ice
visited 122 businesses over the past
five days mostly in Southern California
it's the largest sweep so far this year
agents demand that companies turn over
employment records within three business
days
Mireya Villarreal shows us why some
employers say these check ups are bad
for business
homeland security agents went from
business to business in a five-day sweep
serving dozens of employers with notices
of inspection this is not a raid this is
an administrative Immigration and
Customs Enforcement conducted about 1300
of these workplace audits in 2017 this
year they expect a 300% increase
companies found employing undocumented
workers could face civil fines or even
criminal prosecution it's really
important for America to protect
American jobs for authorized workers and
US citizens they don't take any jobs
mice Poindexter is CEO of his family
business
the Poindexter Nutt company near Fresno
California he says most Americans don't
want these labor-intensive jobs we hire
people all the time they show up they
work two days and they leave his company
is now being audited by ice we've had
somewhere between five and ten percent
of our workforce have voluntarily quit
just over this why are you hiring people
who are not legally documented to work
in the US because they show up with
documentation here's my green card
here's my social security card and it is
illegal for me to question that when the
nut company was audited ten years ago
Poindexter says they were forced to let
go of 70 percent of the workforce
costing the business about two million
dollars he said do you think it's okay
to hire illegals I said I've got a
person with three american-born children
u.s. citizens and have to fire both
their parents Rafael is here illegally
and asked us to conceal his identity his
employer is also being audited and some
co-workers have stopped showing up
asking me
he says they're scared of immigration
arriving at their workplace and taking
them as the sole provider for his family
of six he says his children are worried
they are scared that you're going to get
deported
he says of course with families and
businesses on edge the debate continues
as to whether problems faced by many
states like California will be addressed
by immigration solutions from Washington
the pull factor for people making the
trip is the prospect of gaining
employment if we can eliminate that
factor then that is really an added
element to border security whether Trump
gets his wall or not it doesn't fix it
put up a wall you have a no trespassing
sign and a Help Wanted sign on the same
dang wall California has jobs that need
to be fulfilled and we have people on
the other side of the border that want
them for CBS this morning v-day ovule
near Fresno California what a great
perspective to add to the debate yeah I
was thinking quite an imagery to think
of the imagery no trespassing and Help
Wanted at the same time just shows you
though behind all these policies there's
people's lives that we're talking about
here and you can feel his pain and
passion for this topic in a businessman
who's who has work to be done yes yes to
be tended to and in a close relationship
with knows a way to work this out